[Music]
in detroit over the last three years
over a hundred thousand families have
had their water shut off
i can't touch water or drink water or be
in contact with water without thinking
about somebody not having it
[Music]
my name is monica lewis patrick and i am
the president and ceo of we the people
of detroit
we're committed to the human right to
water
low income people in detroit are having
a hard time paying their water bill
and they're getting their water shut off
when the water department comes out to
shut off the water they mark it with a
blue line and for many of the residents
it's known as the blue line of shame
some people's water is only off for a
matter of days others water has been off
as long as two to three years the issue
of not having access to water is
a really big deal
you can lose custody of your children
you can lose your property you can also
lose your quality of health it just
doesn't set well with me
our job is really to meet that human
need our services are for those families
that can't afford to get their water
turned back on
our water primarily is donated and then
we store it in one of our water stations
and then it is distributed out to the
community based on need
the deliveries that we do every week
make sure that the client has enough
water on an emergency basis to do some
basic things flush the toilet take care
of their basic hygiene prepare their
food
over the last year we've served over a
thousand families
water can unite us and so it's out of
belovedness that we approach our water
work i always like to say i didn't
choose water water chose me
[Music]
you